the question 5 yeah someone needs more
or where can I find more upper beginner
content for Polish right and this ties
into another question as well what what
are some resources for 4 in contact I
mean this comes up all the time is very
important we have some I think very good
material for Polish at link and this is
the learner at link who feels that he's
kind of done all those and wants to find
more upper beginner content my view is
if you've done all of the sort of
beginner upper beginner intermediate
content at link it's time for you to
move into authentic content now having
said that I know that for example with
Portuguese this one link member created
this wonderful series of 20 lessons
where she talked about her trip through
Europe minutes each I'm actually with
her friend they lost their bags it's
very much call it up or beginner lower
intermediate but she spoke naturally
okay and so we hope that at link more
and more of our members I also had that
one of my first Brazilian Portuguese
tutors she did also sort of a diary she
took her kids to the zoo and almost kind
stuff so to the extent the people will
create simple Diaries simple
conversations on everyday life I think
that's what we don't have enough of we
have the sort of learner oriented you
know this is a dog you know Mary you
know is eating your cake for the very
bottom over the very beginning and then
you've got that upper level which is you
know little Chandra has been like a
Portuguese bottled up Brazil your paws
cvn that I doesn't do and the
intermediate stuff should be this sort
of we were hoping you know and we do
have a lot of this kind of content say
that our members that link create where
they either it's a diary or my thoughts
on this or I talked to my friend my
husband my wife my girlfriend my
boyfriend that kind of stuff if we can
get more of that with good sound quality
with the transcript so that you can you
know read it and learn the words that's
what we really need more of as to
finding content
web like you just have to google and
maybe you take it and go to google
translate to get the target language
version of what you're looking for you
know history of Poland or whatever sorry
you know his story I polski okay then
you put his story of polski and you
don't get a lot not sure sure that's
what you have to do yeah you look for
instance I was a-thinkin look at a link
in the Spanish and they found some
really cool content with regarding the
culture see how this lady was talking
about the day of the dead and i wanted
to learn about that instead of going to
wikipedia i drive so I don't like so
it's pretty cool and now obviously in
Spanish we have a lot more content than
we have in Polish polish is a more
recent language and in Polish I went to
porters site I've mentioned before and I
got his stuff and I imported it into
link so sometimes you have to go and
find these resources that's a little
shorter side that's real polish by the
way looking for is not be out give me
another plug okay I got a one-star
polish myself yeah I hope that nollie
Russian will will help me oh absolutely
absolutely the guest declensions it's
one in a systems the same okay the
endings are different but the system the
basics system is largely the same
excellent and are the they resemble each
other every now and then because I
notice that you can publish and crepe or
sorry creation and Russian sometimes the
endings of the words were actually
similar but yeah they some of them like
the instrumental you know the answer
because I am I look at that type but
some are do the genitive you know it
might be a you instead of a liar sure
yeah actually then um question six what
was your experience like learning Korean
Korean I finding very difficult and
because of there are a lot of small
little words there that have seemed to
have six or seven meetings so that what
you look them up it's not that helpful
to the context of em reading and again a
bit of a problem with with content that
is interesting and and yet as my level
so I have these podcasts that i enjoy
but there
the difficult one of them is this kim
jung hwa that i mentioned he talks about
literature when he reads from you know
Mishima ukyo in Korean I'm lost socks
when he talks about yukio mishima you do
yeah I can follow him so a bit of a
problem with the language itself in
terms of a lot of words that seem to
have a lot of meaning and perhaps a lack
of again gets back the whole content
issue yeah absolutely personally I this
may sound Clarets but I've been trying
to learn how to sing Gangnam style oh
yeah you Korean right I probably sound
hilarious but I'm trying to have to get
over any of you saying that whoa I'll
have to practice but should be fine